congratulations you did it after years
of working your fingers to the bone at
the legendary scp foundation putting
your life sanity and perhaps even
immortal soul at risk every single day
you suddenly find yourself standing at
the very tip of the pyramid you can now
learn about the truth behind scp-001
you'd be lying if you said it was an
easy journey you started about one rung
above d-class a mere janitor mopping
hallways and cleaning toilets for
personnel who actually got a piece of
the action not that it meant you didn't
have to experience risk on the job you
remembered one of the most terrifying
moments of your life occurred during
this period back when you were just
cleaning out office space in site 19 you
heard the door rattle behind you and you
rose back up just in time to see
scp-173 standing in the doorway staring
at you you heard about this thing about
how you had to keep your eyes on it or
it would kill you and then everything
else you stared at it eyes watering in
panic hoping to keep it rooted in place
but it was starting to hurt you could
feel yourself straining the surface of
your eyes was so dry was this where you
were going to die perhaps if you hadn't
had the idea you had next you blinked
one eye and then the other keeping one
eye open at all times that kept the
sculpture in place long enough for the
site's security team to locate it and
drag it back to containment you'd saved
your own life and many others that day
and decided in that moment that you may
really have a future here and you
weren't the only one with this level of
confidence hearing about your quick
thinking and heroic bravery the head of
the site security team decided you might
be an ideal candidate for his crew after
the proper training you jumped at the
chance of course to experience the
grueling barrage of physical and mental
courses needed to survive and thrive
under the pressure of being a dedicated
foundation guard before long you became
an accepted member of the security team
and you'd go on to receive further
commendations for your cool-headedness
and bravery during dangerous containment
breaches from
scp-3199
scp-106 and
scp-939 respectively you were quickly
turning into a respected figure among
your foundation peers while some would
be content to coast on that you'd never
been the kind of person who just rests
on their laurels by day you work to keep
site 19 safe from deadly containment
breaches and infiltration from crafty
groups of interests like the chaos
insurgency and the serpent's hand but by
night you were taking online college
courses slowly beefing up your
qualifications in a number of esoteric
research sciences after years of hard
work you requested a transfer from
senior security officer to junior
researcher it'd be a step backwards in
terms of career advancement and you were
also told you'd be getting a pay cut for
your trouble but you didn't care you'd
even start with archival work if it
meant getting closer to the actual
anomalies the foundation was all about
so that's exactly what happened you were
made a junior researcher and your first
job was archival duties sorting and
digitizing years of files with a new
computerized system for some this would
be hell for you it's heaven you're
getting to see it all up close the
deepest darkest secrets of the scp
foundation well
not quite at your low clearance level
there's only a certain amount you're
able to access even when filing things
away stumbling into the wrong files and
attempting to access them can be
actively dangerous too as many of them
are protected with the kind of heavy
duty memetic kill agents that would stop
your heart before you'd even have a
chance to click away but funnily enough
that level of protection only made the
forbidden fruit of knowledge seem more
enticing and the very peak of
curiosities locked under so many layers
of secrecy and encryption was the equal
parts iconic and infamous scp-001
some senior researchers had spread
rumors about the true nature of zero
zero one but nobody truly had the full
scope of it outside of the o5 council
for pretty much everyone else the true
answers would be forever out of reach
like a distant but enrapturing mirage
and it was at that moment that you
decided you'd simply have to become a
member of the 05 council and for the
rest of your life that's exactly what
you were trying to work towards after
all rumor has it that the council has
access to secret life extending
anomalies that they used to linger
around for centuries a single meager
lifetime working toward a seat at that
table would be such a small price to pay
when all was said and done for the next
few decades you did everything you could
to advance your position and climb
through the ranks of this prestigious
organization you published award-winning
research papers on the nature of
thomatology you worked multiple 18-hour
shifts a week getting up close and
personal with some of the most famous
and dangerous anomalies on the books
scp-106 scp-096
and even scp-682
you showed bravery and heroism during
containment breaches staying calm and
keeping the people around you out of
harm's way and as you rise through the
ranks you always kept your goal in mind
you'll uncover the secrets of scp-001
you have to know you will know there is
no other acceptable outcome while
technically speaking 001 is above
classified the scp foundation is an
organization run by humans well mostly
anyway and when humans are involved
nothing will ever be infallible and
after all there's no such thing as a
perfect seal when you're rubbing elbows
with dr gears dr cleff and dr bright
it's natural that some things start to
slip out in conversation even if
strictly speaking it's in defiance of
official foundation protocol but
something strikes you as very strange as
each one tells you about their vision of
scp-001
you notice that each is describing a
completely different thing dr kleff for
example begins covertly telling you
about something known as the gate
guardian also known by the alias yurial
this being is said to act as the bouncer
at the door to paradise he is impossibly
huge with wings made of burning light
and a sword of pure fire that's hotter
than the sun cleft tells you that the
creature's sword is so powerful that it
cleaves its victims apart on the atomic
level completely and utterly destroying
every trace of them though he then
grumbles with visible frustration that
it failed in its attempts to kill
scp-682 adding no surprises there right
as he left to have a smoke dr bright
tells you an incredibly different story
to him scp-001
isn't a being it's a location an
expansive factory from the 19th century
that was created by pure evil occultist
and industrialist james anderson this
place initially seemed like a boon
providing jobs to the needy travelers
and transients across the early united
states but this dream come true soon
revealed itself to be a complete
nightmare anderson was a brutal
taskmaster who not only worked thousands
of people to death but performed
horrifying occult experiments on the
grounds of the cursed building you
started to worry that perhaps dr bright
had a little too much to drink when he
started ranting about how the factory
helped a burgeoning scp foundation
commit genocide against the fey but you
were happy to receive more information
about scp-001
in any case and dr gears told a far more
low-key story than the other two which
was fitting really for a man so
incredibly buttoned down he probably
thought of lucky charm marshmallows as
an almost unspeakable act of
self-indulgence he told the story of a
being he referred to as the prototype a
dangerous and radioactive monster that
functioned as the first truly
threatening creature that the scp
foundation ever faced containing it with
imperfect methods even led to the death
of dr ketter which in turn led to the
naming of the ketter class for any
anomalies that were particularly
challenging to contain you were awash
with data and yet it somehow felt like
you now knew less for sure was scp-001
some kind of umbrella term for a vast
collection of different anomalies each
one either deeply important or somehow
formative for the scp foundation
curiouser and curiouser naturally this
did nothing to deter your boundless
drive to know the true secrets of this
mysterious designation that seemed to
exist at the very heart of the scp
foundation years went on and you went
from a decorated senior researcher to
the site director for site 19. there
through even more years of hard work you
developed a reputation as one of the
greatest directors the site ever had you
reduced containment breaches by a truly
astonishing 80 percent during your
tenure and the breaches that did happen
were significantly less deadly under
your sterling management general
personnel satisfaction skyrocketed with
the people working under you both
enjoying your leadership and respecting
you enough to take you seriously you
were firm but fair a truly exemplary
site director the more you climbed the
more information about scp-001 seemed to
fall into your lap the sheer breadth of
some of these concepts were staggering
the scarlet king the black moon the lock
the broken god a whole laundry list of
terrifying existential threats hiding
just under the thin crust of normalcy
just how much were they hiding from you
were they all real was only one real and
the rest in elaborate smoke screen you
just had to know but even if it took
your whole life a 40-year career with
the scp foundation putting everything at
hazard for a chance to gaze into the
ultimate chest of secrets and eventually
with the mysterious passing of a
previous member of the o5 council which
as far as anyone else knows you had
nothing to do with the position of
05-10 has opened up and who else is next
in line to that throne but you
congratulations
you made it to the next step the big
boys table and the truth about scp-001
comes with the territory you're given an
orientation document written by a prior
05 council member known as lh sign from
the korean branch of the foundation it
promises that after you put in your new
o5 login credentials it'll tell you
everything you need to know about
scp-001
with quaking fingers you type in your
username and password and the page opens
revealing the truth about scp-001
to your eager eyes your jaw drops your
forehead is suddenly doused in the sheen
of cold sweat no you think this has to
be a joke it can't be true your life
your whole life building up to learning
scp-001 does not exist the document in
upsettingly plain terms explains to you
that while some of the anomalies
referred to as
scp-001 do exist in some capacity the
closest funnily enough being dr gear's
story about the prototype for the most
part there is no such thing as 001 and
the finer details are either entirely
fabricated or at the very least greatly
exaggerated everything you've been
working towards it was just one big
fraud perpetrated by the foundation why
you found yourself asking in a trembling
voice why why why and the answer was
simple to provoke the egos of the
foundation's personnel you see while the
foundation has always contained
anomalies that was a means to an end not
the end itself the true purpose of the
foundation is and always has been
protecting people and every anomaly
contained as more people protected
however tricking the lower rungs of the
foundation into believing that there's
some grand final boss to work towards
like a black moon or a scarlet king has
been an effective method of keeping
everyone motivated to swim in the same
direction
this is hardly an unprecedented move for
the scp foundation from their lies
around procedure 110 montauk to the
controlled deception around the rituals
that supposedly keep the devourer of
worlds on the other side of scp-2317
the scp foundation has never shed away
from lying to its own employees for the
greater good but you never expected it
to happen to you and you certainly never
expected it to be about scp-001
you feel like you've been laughed at for
your entire life but now you crack a
quivering smile maybe your mind has
snapped or maybe you're just glad to
finally be in on the joke now go check
out
scp-001 the world's gone beautiful and
scp-001 or boro cycle the full story
compilation for more strange and
original takes on scp-001